apa
auch hier findet sie heimat maria
riccarda wesseling in der nähe von
amsterdam lebt die vielbeschäftigte
mezzosopranistin mit familie und hund
die küste ist ihre erholungsphase und
schafft eine verbindung zur alten heimat
für den bündner bergen bis ganz ein
lasst uns einfach die sterilität ihr
kraft hätte die kommen aus aller welt
die gewalt genauso wichtig spiel
ihren durchbruch als international
gefragte opernsängerin hat sie im jahr
2006 maria riccarda wesseling
erarbeiteten paris das stück iphigenie
auf tauris
eigentlich ist sie nur die
zweitbesetzung für die britische
operndiva susan graham sie ist gar kein
picasso nervös werden
bin sofort ins theater und an die
vorstellung macht
der weg ist geebnet für die große
opernkarriere bilbao wesseling brilliert
als kamen die kritik adelt sie als
lokales ereignis berlin an der
staatsoper singt sie die titelrolle in
der oper phaedra paris die weltberühmte
choreographin pina bausch inszeniert
orpheus wieder eine titelrolle
madrid die bündnerin steht mit
star-tenor placido domingo auf der bühne
später sind sie die hauptrolle in der
oper problem er ohne normaler alltag hat
seltenheitswert bei maria riccarda
wesseling
nur gerade drei monate pro jahr ist sie
zu hause in holland die restliche zeit
lebt die opernsängerin in großstädten in
flugzeugen in klimatisierten räumen
heimkommen ist luxus wichtig
für ihren traum von der opern karriere
musste la besseling die schweiz
verlassen
bekommen hat sie die großen auftritte in
holländischen humor und das multi kulti
leben auch nicht schlecht oder
von amsterdam nach basel
hier am theater singt sie die böse
königin in der oper schneewittchen
einst wollte man sie nicht am baseler
konservatorium aufnehmen
diese kränkung längst vergessen jetzt
spielt sie die hauptrolle
das leben als globale nomaden wird
prägend auf die kunst von maria riccarda
wesseling und stärkt ihre identität ist
ganz klar dass du weit
und ss spyri für andere bereitschaft
augen dann sieht's auch die sprache eine
andere welt andere umgebungen
schlussendlich immer klarer wird wärmer
sein